على الرغم من الظروف الاقتصاديه الصعبه
هكذا تبدو اسواق مدينه عدن في بدايه الشهر
الفضيل الازدحام سيد الموقف والحركه
التجاريه والاقتصاديه على اشدها والمحلات
ممتلئه بالمتسوقين والباعه ينتشرون في كل
مكان ابناء عدن عندنا اجواء خاصه مميزه
لاستقبال رمضان وعاشر رمضان من اقوى نفحات
ايمانيه رائعه وعدت وتقاليد بالماكولات
والمشروبات وتلاقي حتى نفسيات الناس بشكل
دائم نفسها سمحه ومتقبله للاوضاع حتى رغم
المضاع شويه متدهوره لكن الحمد لله ربك
يسر الامور ولرمضان هنا اطعمه وسلع تجعل
للشهر الكريم طابعا خاصا
كجزء من عادات وتقاليد متوارثه من القدم
ورغم الحرب المشتعله في البلاد منذ انقلاب
الحوت عام 2014
وما خلفته من ازمات انسانيه ومعيشيه الا
ان اليمانيين يصرون على احياء طقوس وشعائر
شهر رمضان
كمناسبه دينيه واجتماعيه لها نكهتها الخاص
هنا في مدينه عدن العاصمه المؤقته العادات
والتقاليد في عدن الحمد لله
يعني الانوار بكل مكان والاضاءات وعدم
جميله جدا بشعبها والناس طيبين والزيارات
والسمبوسه والاسواق كيف مقتضى الحمد لله
رغم الغلا لكن احنا عايشين
لا يختلفوا ليل عدم في رمضان نهارها حيث
تتزين المدينه في كل احيائها خصوصا
العتيقه منها وتفتح الاسواق ابوابها حتى
ساعات الفجر
اذن هذه المره استقبلت ان الشهر الكريم
استقبال حافل ومبهر الزينات في الشوارع
كانت ملفته للنظر على خلاف كل عام لا تنام
غدا في شهر رمضان حيث يوحي كلما في هذه
المدينه بطابع خاص لشهر الكريم الذي يصر
الناس هنا لاحياء شعائره والمحافظه على
طابعه الروحي والاجتماعي ردفان الدبيس
العربيه عدن